Interviewer:  [Prakhaim 00:00:00] what sparked your curiosity for pre-Arabic languages?
Prakhaim: You mean pre-Arabic?
Interviewer: Yeah.
Prakhaim: Well, when I attended the university in 1983, I started studying Arabistic, Arabic Studies.
I attended courses in the Arabic morphology, syntax,
and I found out that most of the linguistic phenomena couldn't be explained by the normal methodology which we follow
in Arabic Studies usually, the traditional Arabic Studies.
Which, in fact, in the future, after I got my BA in Arabistic at Yarmouk University in 1987,
I attended a Master program in Epigraphy.
Epigraphy is the study of ancient inscriptions in general, and whether they are incised on rock, or cast in metal
or on wood, really, there are many surfaces.
We can talk about many surfaces where ancient inscriptions are written.	In fact, this study, I mean,
studying epigraphy at Yarmouk University, the Institute of Archeology and Anthropology,
paved my way to understand more about the prehistory of Arabic in general.
Also, it gives me the opportunity to discover more about the cultural history of Arabian Peninsula before Islam,
because through the inscriptions we discover usually facts related to the religious beliefs in Arabia,
as well as historical facts that are not attested in the Arabic sources or in the Arabic tradition.
What I mean, that studying Arabic
and Arabic culture in general would not yield to useful conclusions without studying the ancient Arabian languages in
general.
I mean, every students who attends, who would like to study Arabic and Arabian culture,
should start maybe from the 10th Century BC to have a wide understanding
and a deep understanding about the Arabian Peninsula and its history, its religions, and languages.
Interviewer: You started studying that? Was it a new study? Were you the first or were you one of the first to do that?
Prakhaim: Well, yes.
In fact, my group in fact, in 1987,
were the second group which attended the MA in Epigraphy at the Institute of Archeology and Anthropology,
and we are now more than 30 professors spread over Jordan and worldwide.
This gave us, of course, an impulse to work on further to discover our cultural heritage, our linguistic
and cultural heritage in general. In fact, I'm okay.
I’m at Yarmouk University now, where I studied before, but my stay in Germany, in fact,
I invested my stay in Germany to go in depth in this study.
I tried my best, through German language, to discover more and more about the Arabian culture
and the Arabian cultural history, in addition to Levantine, and also the Horn of Africa.
I'm also interested in the relationship between the Arabian Peninsula and the Horn of Africa,
in addition to a wide historical spectrum covered by my study, either during my MA period and PhD period in Germany.
Interviewer: In the German period, you discovered, or you discovered probably before,
but what I like in your German period, what you describe is how you somehow, through language,
learning the German language, discovered more and more of the German soul, the German culture, the German-
Prakhaim: Yeah, of course. I mean, learning German was of great importance for me.
It paved the way to understand literature written in German in general, and, as you know, German,
or any language you learn, is kind of a key. It's a key to the culture itself.
Not only to literature, but also to the people.
I mean, if you understand the language, if you can deal with the language,
it means that you can discover the culture as well.
Interviewer: German is of course a living language.
It's a language that's been spoken by lots of people in Germany and abroad.
You went on in studying languages that are pre-Islamic?
Prakhaim: Yes. In fact … Well, yes.
If you know the system of a certain language, then it will be easy for you to learn other languages.
I talk now about the grammar of a language. I'm not talking about the script.
Yes, I had the background how to deal with languages in German.
That's why it was for me maybe easy to learn German, and also to deal with it and to write a lot of articles
and publications in German.
Interviewer: When you say once you know how the key, you have easy access to the keys of languages
and of inscriptions so, by having those keys, your generation is one of the first maybe that really just …
Prakhaim: If I say generation, I mean the generation in Jordan.
Europeans took care about this 100, 200 years ago, since 200 years.
We are not the first in this field, and studying the ancient Arabian culture, either in Arabia, the Arabian Peninsula,
or in Levant, the Europeans were pioneers in this regard, I'll say.
Of course, and also they contributed in deciphering the ancient inscriptions, and my generation, which studied abroad,
got the same experience and the same information they gained, I mean, the Europeans has gained before.
Of course, on a daily … Inscriptions are discovered constantly, and some of them are still undeciphered,
but we have of course inscriptions and languages that we understand and we can deal with the text
and draw conclusions from the text, either on the linguistic, cultural, or any other level.
Interviewer: I can imagine that such a beautiful thing that you discover through inscriptions,.
through understanding languages, that you're discovering former cultures and former ..
Prakhaim: Yes. In fact, inscriptions are repositories of ancient history.
Of course, if you discover an inscription, it means that you can understand a lot about the environment
or the locality where the inscription is found.
In certain cases, you can date the site, an archeological site, through the inscription.
I mean, not only pottery, but also other inscriptional material can help us in dating archeological sites,
and we have now, I mean, if the inscription is dated, for example,
then now you have a fixed date of a certain site.	Sometimes the paleography, paleography,
I mean the way you write inscriptions,
it also gives you indications about the … it gives you some information about dating, about dating the site,
but not in exact details.
I mean, also, if you discover an inscription which is new and you are the first one who read it and understand it,
then you convey to the humanity and you experience a new information that are, in my opinion,
of great importance to understand the human creativity..
Interviewer: When you decipher such an inscription, what does that do for ..
It opens a window to a culture that was once here?
Prakhaim: Yeah, of course.
I mean, you understand, as soon as you discover and decipher an inscription and understand it,
of course it opens a window to a lot of historical facts and cultural,
historical facts about the region where it is discovered.
Interviewer: When you say that you are, your generation, is one of the first from Jordan
or from the Arabian Peninsula investigating or doing scientific research on these inscriptions, what does that mean,
that you are the first from this region to do that? What does that say of …?
Prakhaim: It means a lot.
It means that we have now a generation from Jordan, from the area,
from the region in general which can deal with its cultural heritage and understand it in the same historical
and geographical context.
If I talk about … I mean Europeans, they contributed in deciphering the inscriptions,
they contributed in understanding the inscriptions, but sometimes, some of them of course, some of them,
they lack the cultural background. I have to say that frankly.
Some of them, they lack the cultural background,
therefore their understanding of the entire story is a little bit vague. Now, in fact, we are not working alone here.
We are working also with our European colleagues in Europe, mainly in Europe and the United States and other countries,
and we exchange opinions about certain issues in this regard. After that, we reach a conclusion.
Interviewer: But you bring in some extra layer, or a very important layer, because you are from this-
Prakhaim: Yes, from the same region. Yeah.
Yes, but I have to say my European colleagues also help in different regards, in different perspectives.
We conduct joint surveys. We conduct also joint studies together.
I think it’s important not from the scientific perspective,
but also from the cultural perspective because it’s important to get in contact with our European colleagues.
I mean, not only Europeans but outside Jordan, our colleagues from outside Jordan to have exchange,
which means that we can do more for cultural understanding as well.
Interviewer: Everybody say that as you’re born here, you’re raised here, you’re part of this culture,
and you are one of the first working in this field and understanding those languages,
that makes you a … that I can imagine that’s a very special role you have.
A very important role, a very special role.
Prakhaim: Yes, I personally can’t evaluate myself, whether I have a special role or not.
It’s the academic world which would decide this..
I’m not the one who decides that because I can’t [crosstalk 00:14:07]
Interviewer: No, but what you do is you shed light on times that people here seems before not know much about.
At least, how do you see that?
Prakhaim: Yeah, that is true. Yeah, this is true.
Well, some generations … I mean, what I want to say, that to be broadminded
and to accept the opinion of others is crucial to understand and to exchange ideas,
and also to reach reliable conclusions.
I think that who would like to study this, the culture in general, should have a broad knowledge about a lot of things,
not only history, not only languages, but also ancient history and also modern history and ancient cultures
and modern culture.
They are not separateable.	We cannot separate them because, I mean, [Batians 00:15:17]
who lived in this area for a long time, they existed after that.
What I’m talking about is the change of political entities while the people are the same.
The people are the same, and they also continue to live in this area, in this region.
I think we have to take into consideration a lot of perspectives towards studying a certain topic
or a certain subject in our cultural history in general. Studying the past is connected with our living heritage.
We cannot separate them.
Interviewer: The fact that you shed light on the times that, before,
people here wouldn’t know much about because it was not-
Prakhaim: Yeah.
Interviewer: Why is it? Why is it that you are one of the first to do just that?
Prakhaim: No, I have some colleagues who are older than me and did that of course,
but I think it’s important to have a generation here who is interested in its cultural heritage and cultural history.
Interviewer: What I want to say is by being one of the first Jordanian, professor now
but one of the scientists researching, investigating inscriptions and languages
and shedding light on a time that somehow is not known about,
why is it that those times … what makes those times were not seen or not accepted or not embraced before?
Prakhaim: Yes, because if I take the Arabian Peninsula as an example, the Arabic sources, for example,
that brought about the Arabian … that were concerned with the Arabian Peninsula and its history, they didn’t get,
in fact, the access to ancient sources because at that time they hadn’t the instruments that give them the access,
for example, to ancient South Arabian epigraphy or ancient North Arabian epigraphy or Novatian epigraphy.
We are talking about a 200 years old discipline, not that ancient. It’s not that old. Yeah.
We can expect that such Arabic sources do not cover the entire … I mean, they cover maybe 200 years before Islam,
for example, but they don’t go deeper into history because the composer and the authors,
they didn’t have the access into such an epigraphical source.
Interviewer: That sort-
Prakhaim: That’s why it’s important to take into consideration the archeological sources and epigraphical sources,
as well maybe oral history as well. It’s also important.
I mean, oral history is important to understand ancient cultures because the same people are still living.
I mean, the same people who established the ancient cultures, their descendants are still there. Yeah.
That’s why I feel it’s important to study the Arabian Peninsula in a holistic approach,
where we can take into consideration the epigraphical sources, the archeology, in addition also to a living heritage.
Interviewer: When you say like before, the ancient [inaudible 00:19:41]
and cultures were not really part of the Arabic storytelling, of the Arabic history, that’s now changing then,
I suspect, because you bring them the stories of those days?
Prakhaim: Yes. Yeah, and now we have a new window to ancient history of the Arabian Peninsula. There is a new one.
This new window was not possible to open without studying and deciphering the inscriptions,
deciphering the ancient Arabian and Semitic inscriptions in general. Yeah.
Interviewer: What does this window … Because I suppose much of the students you get,
they are taught in a way that they don’t understand those times before.
Prakhaim: Yes.
Interviewer: How do they see that era when they come in your faculty?
Prakhaim: Yeah, that’s a good question.
In fact, students who come to our faculty, they have their own stereotype ideas about Arabia
or about the Semitic cultures in general, but when they get deeply involved in this field,
they start changing their understanding
and also their methodology towards studying the cultural history of the Semitic world.
Interviewer: What is their view when they come in?
How do they see them when they don’t have this knowledge, the kind of ignorant times or-.
Prakhaim: In fact, most of our students who are coming to the ..
I mean,
in fact they are selected because they know in pre-year what are they going to do because they have a little knowledge
about this and about the cultural history of Arabia and the Semitic world in general.
At the Institute, we train them and we conduct surveys so that they understand what we are doing in a better way.
Interviewer: What is, I suppose, the view that they have … The people from Jordan or from the Arabian Peninsula,
how do they see in general the times before Islam?
Prakhaim: In fact, the Arabian Peninsula was a flourish … they had a flourishing civilization in Arabia before Islam,
and the word “Jahiliyyah” or the ignorance period,
I think it’s not the right word to use in this context because ignorance,
it means that the people who were living there were ignorant and they were not in contact with the civilization,
et cetera, but this is in fact a little bit … I mean, the idea should be modified a little bit.
In fact, Arabia witnessed a flourishing culture economically and historically and culturally in general.
It’s our rule now to present this culture, which was hidden in the inscriptions.
Interviewer: That’s your role?
Prakhaim: Yeah.
Interviewer: Present? That’s your role?
Prakhaim: I mean,
to present the contents of this ancient heritage to be absorbed by the young generation because it’s part of their
identity, it’s part of their history.
I think it’s our role now to make them aware that Arabia is not … I mean maybe Jahiliyyah in terms of the religious
perspective, but from the civilized perspective Arabia, I think, especially the southern parts and the central parts,.
they are of a great importance and significance to understand the … Okay, I’m [inaudible 00:23:59].
Interviewer:  [inaudible 00:23:59]
Prakhaim: I think the sources give us a new glimpse.
I mean, the ancient sources, the ancient inscriptions give us new glimpses on the hidden history
and the hidden culture of Arabia before Islam.
This is now evident through research and through archeological surveys, and through also studies published.
You have thousands of publications in this regard, but most of them in fact are written in foreign languages.
That’s why they are not accessible by Arab people.
It’s our role now to, I mean, not to translate them, this is a huge literature,
but to present the cultural history of Arabia in Arabic world.
I think this is important now so that Arab people can have access to this source.
Interviewer: When you studied several languages, you can lay connections so you create, I think,
the worlds that had been here that before was not understood by people.
Prakhaim: You mean the scholarly world or what?
Interviewer: No, both.
You’re putting a light on times that for most people was not known yet, so people understand now that, for example,
here in Petra, that this is the culture of what it stands for.
Prakhaim: Yes, of course. I have to say I’m not the first one in this regard, of course.
Interviewer: Of course. I know.
Prakhaim: But understanding … I mean, if you talk about epigraphy or the ancient languages, yes of course,
as I said in the beginning, they are in fact the key to cultures.
The Batian inscriptions are written in the Batian language, in the Batian script,
and if you decipher the scripts then you understand the language
and you understand after that the contents of a certain inscription.
From this inscription, you can extract and draw conclusions regarding religious history, regarding commercial issues,
regarding social relations among people at that time.
I mean, through this knowledge, you can nurture the history of their region of course. Yeah.
Interviewer: Do you see that also, that there are connections between the pre-Arabic worlds and the Arab world?
That somehow, I mean, like … Yeah, do you see connections that before had not been seen?
Prakhaim: Between the pre-Arab-
Interviewer: Pre-Islamic worlds and the Islamic world.
Prakhaim: Yeah. Yes, of course. Yes.
Yes, of course, because people continue to exist in Arabia,
and of course they got with them ancient traditions that continued until nowadays.
Interviewer: Do you have examples of that?
Prakhaim: Well, let us say something.
Some ancient South Arabian inscriptions from Yemen, from present Yemen,
in fact we rely on Yemeni dialects to understand the ancient inscriptions because some words that were there in ancient
South Arabian inscriptions, they are still used in Yemen. This is a fact.
Also, some rituals that existed, that we know from the inscriptions, are still existing until nowadays in Yemen,
which means that this culture continue to exist apart of political changes, apart of economic changes,
but people have preserved this cultural heritage and continued to transmit it.
Interviewer: You said also the camel burial? Or is that another …?
Prakhaim: No, it’s something different.
Interviewer: That is something different? Okay, sorry for that. One …
Prakhaim: That’s something different.
I mean, the camel burial inscriptions, okay, it’s from Wadi Rum,
but this is an evidence about resurrection that people in Arabia used to bury their camels with them so that they …
Speaker 1: The camera has stopped. Maybe we should stop …
Interviewer: Where did your passion for languages and inscription start?
Prakhaim: Well, in fact this passion started after my … in fact, during my BA studies in Jordan,
at Yarmouk University. At Yarmouk University.
I tried my best to understand the Arabian culture in more deep and with more depth,
but I didn’t find this during my BA studies because we were studying Arabic
and Arabistic in general in a traditional way, studying the languages not in a diachronic way but in synchronic way.
I started looking for programs that could help me in deciphering the ancient history of Arabic in general
and the ancient history of the Arabian culture.
That was after 1987, when I attended a Master program at the Institute of Archeology and Anthropology,
where I studied Epigraphy
and I finished my MA in Epigraphy.	My Master thesis was concerned with the lexical relationship between Arabic
and Ugaritic. Ugaritic is one of the Bronze Age, late Bronze Age languages that existed on the Mediterranean Sea.
I tried to find the lexical affinities between Arabic … some scholars call the classical Arabic or standard Arabic.
There are different terminology. I mean, here, the Arabic of Koran and the pre-Islamic Arabian poetry.
I found out that there are a lot of aspects that constitute the kind of lexical similarity between Ugaritic and Arabic.
Yes, because this could be of course explained because both languages, they have the same mother language,
which we call it … It’s a hypothetical language.
We call it Proto-Semitic.	This lexical stuff could be from this genetic relationship,
but this relationship could be also through historical factors, by migrations, by historical contacts,
commercial contacts, et cetera, but we have a lot of historical models to explain this similarity.
In general, most of the languages in Levant, the Levant and Arabia, and also in Mesopotamia, they are interconnected.
We call them sister languages because they come from the same origin. The origin, we call it Proto-Semitic.
Interviewer: To go back, what is your fascination for these old languages?
Prakhaim: Yes, because in general I found the languages very … I mean,
studying the language provide us with their right instruments to decipher cultures.
I mean, for example, I did for five years the ancient Ethiopic, old Ethiopic language because my professor in Berlin,,
Professor [Rhiner Folkt 00:33:12] he is a renowned professor in this field.
I did with him five years studying ancient Ethiopic or old Ethiopic. Why?
Because I wanted to understand the relationship between Arabia and the Horn of Africa.
I mean, studying the language would explain a lot of historical facts
and historical phenomena in terms of relationship between Arabia and the Horn of Africa. This is an example.
As I said to you, because I was interested in exploring the history of Arabic language
and the Arabic culture in general.
Interviewer: Even before your studies, where did this fascination for languages
and for these … where did it start and-
Prakhaim: Yes. I was interested in languages even during my childhood.
Also, my … That’s I was interested in English from the beginning, although I was studying Arabic,
because I found out that studying a certain language would open
and pave the way for me to get a deep information about certain aspects of our cultural history.
From the beginning, I was interested in languages, but I can’t say how this evolved at the beginning..
Speaker 1:  [inaudible 00:34:54]
Interviewer: When you were really young, I mean when you were 10 or 11, how did it show? What was the fascination then?
Prakhaim: The fascination in languages?.
Interviewer: Mm-hmm (affirmative)
Prakhaim: I can’t remember. I mean, I can’t make a sense of this in this regard.?
Interviewer: Did you want to discover the world, understand the world? Did you want to be a [inaudible 00:35:26]
Prakhaim: I don't know. I can say that we had no Internet at that time.
The TV also was not accessible at that time because I was born in a village where electricity didn’t exist at that
time until 1982, in fact. We had a radio and that was our window to the world.
Of course I heard a lot of languages in the radio. I found out later that this is German, this is French.
At that time, I couldn’t differentiate between German, French or Dutch or Swedish or Russian, but
when I started to hear … I mean, there were voices, only voices for me,
but there are certain points where the pronunciation is different from each other.
Maybe this is one of the reasons why I was interested. I mean, I was interested in languages, because-
Interviewer: How did you listen into the radio? Can you describe? This was in the living room?
How did you know that you could find different languages?
Prakhaim: Yeah, I can’t tell you. It was in the living room of course, yes. I don’t understand your question.
Interviewer: How do you … It’s a radio. You hear those language. How did you do it?
Were you scrolling through the channels?
Prakhaim: Yes, yes, scrolling through the channels and trying to … Even within the Arabic sphere,
and I try to … We have many dialects here in the Arab world and it was for me, at the beginning,
difficult to understand, for example, the Algerian or the Moroccan dialect.
This is one example why I tried to have the right instruments to study languages because the Arabic dialects,
they could be considered as languages because sometimes they have different morphology and different syntax.
This made me also enthusiastic to pursue studying languages.
In fact, I can’t classify the factors why I was interested in language from the beginning. I don't know.
I have no personal synthesis about this. Yeah.
Interviewer: You were from a family that’s also scientific interested or …?
Prakhaim: Yes.
In fact, my family, they were interested in … I mean, my father is a businessman and my family in general,
they used to earn money through business.
It was my uncle, in fact, my elder uncle, who supported me
and opened my eye to the academic world because he is considered one of the first graduates from the Jordan University.
In fact, he supported my career, my studies,
and also opened my eyes towards the world because he got in contact with the people in Amman, in the capital city,
and also worldwide. That’s why he wanted me to deviate from the career of my family a little bit.
Interviewer: When you [inaudible 00:39:28] described your … Well. What sparked your curiosity?
Prakhaim: Well, regarding languages? Yeah. In fact, I am a patient guy.
I have to say, I’m very patient, even from childhood.
I used to help my father in his store and in his business since I was seven years old, in fact. I have to say that.
This part of my life, this shaped my life to be a serious person because I didn’t … in fact,
I didn’t enjoy most of the children my age enjoyed before.
My father wanted me to be the best among the … in the village
and he sent me first to a Roman Catholic school in Irbid. That was in 1970.
The story of my academic life
or my school life started there.	Due to the problems that occurred in Jordan at that time,
well my father preferred that I go back to the village and to study there and to continue studying there,
doing my preparatory, my elementary preparatory and secondary schooling, I did it in the village,
and even in a village nearby where … and I used to walk from my house to that village for three kilometers sometimes.
Maybe this stimulated me to think about the world and about sometimes the creation, about a lot of things,
where usually school boys think sometimes.
Some of them, they don’t think about it because they have their other interests.
In fact, even this influenced my life and my future life, the university, even in Germany, and also later,
I can see.	Well, during the preparatory and elementary period or phases, we used to study Arabic poetry,
ancient Arabic poetry, and I was fascinated in fact with the contents of the Arabic poetry
and how they can be recited in a rhythmic style.
I was interested also to understand the words used in such passages, poetical passages.
I can assure you that later I found out that our teachers, sometimes they explained in a traditional way,
they explained some words in a traditional way, but I was not convinced.
I was not convinced mostly in their explanations.	I keep this until I went to the university in 1983 where I attended
the Arabic Program at Yarmouk University, and we went, in fact with the assistance of professors of Arabic Studies,
we went in depth in studying the ancient Arabic poetry, but the problem, I didn’t find a solution for my problem.
I mean, how to understand the Arabic poetry in a proper way
and what are the origins of certain words in this Arabic poetry,.
and also to explain how a linguistic phenomena could be ..
How could we explain a certain linguistic phenomena in Arabic in particular, and within this wide context, I mean,
within this wide Arabic context, where Arabic is used.
As you know, Arabic is used in different parts of the world,
and in fact that was not enough for me because I started to excavate
and to dig for the origins of Arabic.	I found some of the answer during my MA studies.
My MA studies where we’re exposed to, in fact, I have to say European experience.
I was taught by different European professors and American professors at the Institute of Archeology.
and Anthropology at that time. We were exposed to ..
Also, we attended courses to study, for example, Canaanite, Ancient South Arabian, Old Ethiopic, Aramaic, et cetera,
and all of these languages are sister languages and go back to one source or to one origin,
which we called Proto-Semitic.
Now, this in fact opened and paved the way for my future research, and since then I was interested in studying more
and more, more ancient languages to understand Arabic and its context in a proper way. Well, as I-
Interviewer: What makes now you unique in the world? It makes you unique.
Prakhaim: Yes.
Interviewer: Why?
Prakhaim: I’m afraid of this word “unique.”
Interviewer: It does?
Prakhaim: Yeah.
I’m trying to connect and to find the relationship between Arabic and its cultural and linguistic context.
This is what I’m trying to show not only to my colleagues, also to my students, and also to make it known abroad.
This methodology was not known in fact in the Arab world,
how to connect Arabic with its surrounding languages through ages and also the culture where Arabic emerged. Yeah.
This influenced, of course, my future studies and future research. I did my MA.
I did my MA thesis on the relationship between Arabic and Ugaritic,
because Arabic is an important source because it’s a language which existed and continue to exist in Arabia
and the Levant also and of course in North Africa.
Interviewer: One second, what do we have here?.
Prakhaim: We hear the Adhan, Adhan [al Asr 00:47:01]
Interviewer: What is that Adhan Asr?
Prakhaim: Yeah. I mean, as you know, we have Islamic prayers, five prayers.
This is the … We call it Adhan al Asr, which comes after afternoon.
Interviewer: You said at a certain moment when you were young you listened to this Arabic poetry.
and [inaudible 00:47:26] I'm sorry?
Prakhaim: In fact, it was included in the curricula of the school. Yeah.
Also, I hear that some people improvised it
and I was interested in understanding the meaning of this poetry in a proper way.
We usually … People recite this poetry,
but they sometimes don’t understand the cultural backgrounds of this poetry.
I was interested in the cultural background, not only on how to be recited.
It’s beautiful to hear it, but I was interested in understanding the cultural dimensions of this poetry
and its language.
Interviewer: You missed that in the recital?
Prakhaim: Yes.
This is what I missed in fact during my school period, also I can say even during my BA period at the university,
because they used to teach us in a traditional way, trying to explain.
They couldn’t explain the cultural backgrounds of this poetry.
Not only the cultural backgrounds,
but also the contained lexical items that were for me very difficult to understand as a young guy,
because the Arabian poetry represents, or the Arabic poetry, represents a very old stage of the Arabic literature
and I can’t say that it was disconnected from the people,
but it represented a certain cultural phase in the Arabian peninsula.
In future stages of my life, I was interested to understand in depth the cultural background
and the cultural context of this poetry. Also, the Koran, the beginning of Islam.
I mean, the language of Koran was also for me a very difficult language to understand,
and I think we can shed some light on the Koranic text from different languages that existed in Arabia before Islam,
because some words continued to be used ….
Interviewer:  [inaudible 00:49:58]
Prakhaim: … continued to be used at that time and also they were part of the Koranic Text,
and I was interested in understanding such words in Koran and I have some research on this regard.
I started a project on this regard. Yeah.
Interviewer: To go back, do you remember the poem, the first poem that makes you …?
Prakhaim: Well, in fact,
I’m interested in the pre-Islamic Arabian poetry which goes back to the so-called Jahiliyyah poetry
or the Jahiliyyah Age or the ignorance period.
For example, the poems of Antar and Zuhayr bin Abi Sulma and other poets.
Interviewer: Can you recite one?.
Prakhaim: Well, no. Not .. No. Also, [inaudible 00:50:59] and other people. Other people.
I wasn’t prepared to do this, because if you-
Interviewer: Then I'd like to go back to the last thing which you said about Koranic.
Prakhaim: Yeah.
Interviewer: What are you doing with that?
You see that it also notice disconnect from the people, but somehow it’s a language form that is not-
Prakhaim: I mean, the poetry was definitely not connected.
It emerged in a cultural context, of course, because this poetry describes the people,
describes their relationship with the environment. It describes also their understanding of the world at that time.
Interviewer: Sorry.
I mean, when we go back to do Koran, the Koranic, you were saying that you now, with what you’re finding,
you are finding new words also for the Koran or you find new lexical-
Prakhaim: No. I’m not finding new words. No.
I mean, well, there are certain Koranic words that could be interpreted in a different way.,
Okay, the Arab [inaudible 00:52:13] they contributed a lot to understanding the Koran,
but in some cases we can do more to understand this text through the languages that existed in Arabia at that time.
Interviewer: Because they have also their roots?
Prakhaim: Yes, of course. I mean, such words, they have their roots in the languages of Arabia before Islam. Yeah.
I mean, we have, for example, some words that were Arabized. They became Arabic.
Although they are foreign words, but they became Arabic and they became part of the Arabian linguistic culture
and you found them in different pre-Islamic Arabian texts.
Also, some of them are known in the Koranic text, because they are not in fact … they were foreign words,
but they were Arabized. They took the Arabic shape.
As usual, in the interchange between languages, it’s known and have been-
Interviewer: You are discovering that now from your …?
Prakhaim: Well, I’m trying to deal with certain words and to understand them in a different lexical context.
Interviewer: What do you mean by that?
Prakhaim: I mean, to interpret them in the light of ancient Semitic languages that existed in Arabia before Islam.
Interviewer: Can you give examples?,
Prakhaim: Yes. There are some examples.,
I mean, for example, the verse [foreign language 00:54:03] which has been interpreted, “We opened your chest,”
and there are different interpretations, but we go back, for example, to ancient South Arabian linguistic culture,
we find that the root “ [sharha 00:54:24] ”, it means to protect, which means, in fact,
if we reinterpret this word, it means that we … I mean, God has protected Muhammad’s heart.
This helps us to understand the text in a better way and it’s for the benefit of Koran, in fact.
It’s for the benefit of Koran to use the ancient languages and to shed light on Koran through other language,
other Arabian languages..
Interviewer: Okay. Then we go back to when you .. We were with your students.
You were with your students in the mountains, looking at the stones and this enormous terrain.
When you look for them and for yourself, when you envision your future, the ideal dream of what they can do,
what you can do here in this area, how do you envision that over 10, 15 years?
Prakhaim: Well, how do I envision my students or the field in general?.
Interviewer:  [inaudible 00:55:36] I put the question wrong.
When you look in your field of work with your students, you would walk into boundaries, as what you explained before.
What do you envision for the coming 10 years or what do you want them to find out
and what is it that you yourself want to find out?
Prakhaim: I would like to continue in this field,
and of course I hope that my students can continue as well because this is a message that we have to hand out to other
future generations. I hope that we can establish a kind of school, I mean, a school, academic school, to understand ...
Which aims at understanding our Arabian culture from the Arabian Peninsula and also in the Levant. Yeah.
That’s what my aim, that they continue on the same discipline
and also that they continue also in training the future generations.
Interviewer: When you look, because you walk into limitations,
you said you were the first one that shed a light in an era where much of the people, you didn’t see the light.
What do you think that your students will … what kind of windows are they able to open?.
Prakhaim: Well, I hope .. I mean, of course they can … I don’t know.
I mean, it’s of course their decision to follow my discipline or not,
but definitely they are going to contribute in understanding the Arabian culture in its widest context.
I'd like them to work on the history of Arabic.
I would advise them to work intensively on the history of Arabic as a language and culture.
For the future, I think because they have now a wide knowledge, I mean, a wide knowledge in languages,
modern languages and also ancient languages,
and they have also the capability … they are capable to deal with other cultures.
Not only ancient cultures, also more modern cultures in the world.
I think they have more and better opportunity than I have, what I had before. Yeah.
Interviewer: A lot of stones, too.
Prakhaim: Yes.
I mean, okay, we have to continue documenting the inscriptions spread all over the Jordanian terrain
and this needs many generations in the future to be prepared for this task.
It’s not a task of one generation or two generations.
We have to train many generations so that they can continue documenting our cultural heritage.
I mean, not only stones and inscriptions, but also archeology and tangible heritage and intangible heritage.
I can’t divide culture into parts. They are all interconnected.
There are a lot of aspects that are interconnected and can … after my studying these aspects,
we can draw a clear picture about our culture.
Interviewer: What are you doing now? What is your focus now?
Prakhaim: Now, I am involved in different projects and research endeavors in general.
I’m now conducting a field work.
It’s a long … It’s a field work which I’m going to continue for the next few years in the so-called
[Harra 01:00:08] Region, in the volcanic region we visited.
I’m also trying to involve foreign institutions to work with me in this field work.
We are trying to document as far as possible the ancient North Arabian inscriptions from Northern Jordan
and from the so-called Northeastern Badia.
It has a lot of … I mean, the surfaces of stones constituted an ideal [canva 01:00:51] for writing inscriptions.
Those inscriptions were written by people who were in the area.
Maybe they had a Bedouin character, but it is not definite,
and there is a countless number of inscriptions in this area
and they need to be documented for future studies so that we understand more and more about the people and the area
and the history of the area.
Interviewer: When you look around you, the whole Jordan, this was a land of milk and honey.
Prakhaim: Yes.
Interviewer: I mean, it’s one big archeological black hole you still have to discover.
Prakhaim: Yes. I mean, I’m not the only person.
In fact, in my institute at the Yarmouk University and the other institutes you saw today,
you have found out that we are trying to train students and to train new generation to take the burden,
to continue this responsibility in studying the cultural heritage of Jordan.
Interviewer: What I want to say, all these rocks have a story.
Prakhaim: Yes, of course.
Interviewer: You are the one so far that found some of the stories,
but I mean this is one big landscape of rocks wanting to speak.
Prakhaim: Yes. In fact, this is true, but-
Interviewer: What is true? Sorry?
Prakhaim: I mean, everywhere you find inscriptions, everywhere you find aspects of cultural heritage here in Jordan.
As I said, we need generations and generations that continue to document and study this cultural heritage.
It is an evidence that this area contributed in the human history.
It is an evidence … What we see here is an evidence that this area, this region contributed to the human creativity.
It’s an evidence on human creativity.
We are trying to widen the spectrum of this knowledge, not only among the academics
but also among the local community so that they can feel that they have old history and they are proud of.
Interviewer: So that they understand that old history and that they’re proud of it?
Prakhaim: Yes.
This is our intention, not only studying the cultural heritage in academic way, but also to let people know
and to let the community know that they have ancient history which contributed in the development of humanity as part
of the development of civilizations. Yeah.
Interviewer: It’s quite a struggle.
Prakhaim: Yeah. I mean, I don’t know. This is something … but this is evident. I mean, as you see, everywhere …
Interviewer: For you, it is evident.
Prakhaim: Huh?
Interviewer: For you, it’s evident, but this is also for the people evident?
Prakhaim: I mean, for the people, I don’t think so.
I don’t think that old people in Jordan, it’s evident for them that Petra, for example,
that it’s contributed in the human development and the human civilizations.
For my father, for example, he never visited Petra.
He’s from the local Jordanian community, but he didn’t visit Petra before. I’m speaking of myself. Yes.
Interviewer: Why not?
Prakhaim: Well, okay, he’s 72 years old. He has his own interests.
He’s a businessman and he’s maybe not interested in this field,
but I promised him to take home to Petra in maybe one or two years. I’m trying to convince him. My concern-.
Interviewer: Is it difficult to convince him? You are the one that ...
Prakhaim: Yes. That’s [crosstalk 01:05:07]
Interviewer: … discovered its history, I mean.
Prakhaim: This is the paradox because I'm the one who should make him aware about our ancient heritage,
but I'm now concerned …
Interviewer: What you’re saying is, it is strange, your father-
Prakhaim: Yes.
Interviewer: You want … you opened the window and your father has to be convinced to join you
and look through the window?
Prakhaim: Yes, through my window. Yeah. Yes, this is a kind of paradox.
I can’t explain that, but he didn’t get the right education to be aware of the importance of our cultural heritage.
We are trying this within the generation now. Yeah.
Interviewer: When you look at this paradox,
because your father stands for much more people than … he stands for the Jordan, for the general opinion about it.
Prakhaim: No, not necessarily general opinion. No.
I mean, in his age, there are people who are interested, who are interested in this heritage and-
Interviewer: Is it sometimes, do you feel lonely … Is it sometimes difficult to know so much of that beautiful era
and, as you see, so many people that you’re going to convince or try to convince,
is it also a lonely feeling that you are one of the few that understands it?
Prakhaim: Yes. Sometimes, yes. Yeah, this is true.
I feel myself sometimes alone even among my colleagues at the university.
Interviewer: Why? How come? Why?
Prakhaim: I mean, not in my faculty, but in general.
Interviewer: Yeah, but it was-
Prakhaim: Young generation now is interested in different things, in IT and business administration, finance,
et cetera.
This field is not … Okay, it’s respected in Jordan, but students mostly are interested,
or young generation is interested in majors through which they can earn money.
I have to admit, through archeology and heritage, this is sometimes difficult. Yeah.
Interviewer: That makes you lonely?
Prakhaim: Well, yeah. Maybe yes. Yeah.
Maybe, but I have some colleagues here in Jordan with whom I can communicate and exchange ideas.
I have also colleagues from Europe and the States, in the United States, and we exchange ideas and opinions,
but mostly we remain in the academic realm. That’s the problem..
The challenge now, how to raise awareness about the importance ..
I mean, how to raise awareness among the community members about this important cultural heritage,
which should be disseminated and get known to a wide range of people. This is a challenge.
I mean, okay, as an academic, I do my part, but there are other parties that can work with us.
For example, the media now, media can reach everybody in his room
and I think we have to work on this now in the next stage.
Interviewer: Yeah.
Then you do your start with the rest of the history of Jordan because this also has to be discovered
or has to be understood?
Prakhaim: Yeah. It have to be studied, discovered, explored. Yeah, but I’m just one person.
That’s why I said that we have to build a generation to get involved in studying this culture.
Interviewer: Yeah. What is your dream? When you’re thinking 10, 15 years, what is your ideal Jordan look like?
Prakhaim: Jordan-
Interviewer: As in, in your-
Prakhaim: In my field?
Interviewer: In your field.
Prakhaim: Yes.
I expect or I hope and wish that we are going to establish an academic school here in Jordan,
academic school not in terms of university or in the way of thinking in this field.
I think I’m part of this generation now, because I was trained in Jordan for my BA and MA,
and I’m very proud to get my first training in Jordan and it was consolidated by my study in Germany
and my academic stays in Europe and the United States.
I’m sure that we are going further and try with the future generation, of course, to build this academic school,
this academic school of thought in the field of cultural heritage in general. Yeah.
Interviewer: When you look at the field where you’re now researching, where we were before,
is it like … that’s quite a lot of work also, all those stones. Are all those stones ready?
Prakhaim: Yeah, not all the stones.
As we have seen yesterday, we had to penetrate in the desert for 40 kilometers to find the place,
to find the site where we worked before.
Yes,
there's a countless number of such inscriptions that’s spread over the stones in the desert right there in the north,
I mean, Northeastern Badia. Yeah, of course, they need expertise. They need scholars.
They need more trained students and also research institutions.
It was I suggested once a day to establish a kind of a research center there in the desert, so that such inscriptions,
such archeology, such science can be easily accessible to us. Yeah.
I mean, this is one of my dreams, to establish a research center there.
Speaker 1: Where do they publish their findings?
Interviewer: Where do they publish their findings?
Prakhaim: Well, usually either we publish the findings in books or we publish them in journals in different languages,
Arabic, German, English. Yeah.
Those languages are accessible for us, and sometimes in French, because some of my colleagues graduated from France
and England, for example, and they prefer to write in the languages they mastered.
Interviewer: Here in Jordan?.
Prakhaim: Yes. Of course, we have ..
In fact the academic situation and the level of education in Jordan is good here
and it has a high standard in comparison to other institutions in the region.
Interviewer: Can you, for example, also the stories that shed light on this era, pre-Islamic era,
is it easy to share it with the general public? Is it allowed?
Prakhaim: Yeah, of course. Yes. Yeah, yeah. I mean, we can share it with the public.
We hold conferences about our new discoveries.
In a few, I think it will … we are planning for a workshop I think in March,
2016 on this subject about new discoveries in Jordan, new epigraphical discoveries in Jordan. Yes.
There's no problem to share the information with the public, because sometimes we compose our articles
and research papers in Arabic and Arabic is accessible for everybody in Jordan.
Interviewer: Now that you kind of mentioned about it, but I’m also meaning is it is sometimes, I suppose,
difficult to … when you have a lot of people who think of the time before as ignorant, as an ignorant time,
to let them know and look through this window, you see a different world.
Prakhaim: Yes. Yeah..
Interviewer: Like what you’re saying about what you’re doing with [inaudible 01:14:05]
Prakhaim: Yeah, this is true.
In fact, the best way is to implement
or to use the modern media to make the people aware about what we are discovering.
I’m trying my best now to convince my university to integrate this discipline, this academic discipline,
into different academic fields.
Not only in archeology, in the archeological context, but also maybe in the Department of Arabic Studies,
because the Arabic Studies, Departments of Arabic Studies in the Arab world,
they are in fact not totally concerned with the ancient sources that we encounter in Arabia before Islam.
Interviewer: What is the essence of what they are finding, what you are finding?
Prakhaim: Yes. In fact, it’s very essential to understand cultural, historical aspects on the basis of inscriptions.
For example,
we know that Arabia has had always a constant contact with the surrounding that we discovered through the inscriptions,
through the texts. We know, for example, that Arabia had contacts with Egypt, with Greece, with Asia, with the other ...
With the Asian Modern Turkey, which was Asia Minor, and also with other remote areas.
For example, in the Semite say, they reached Morocco and reached Tunisia and Morocco.
Through the inscriptions, we can find out how those people, how the Semitic people in this area were in strong
and constant contact with the other people in the world.
Interviewer: Why is it you work … You find all these findings, and it’s very important information,
but we look around in a part of the world where all kind of conflicts emerge now around Jordan.
Prakhaim: Yeah.,
Interviewer: Which is all about historical, well, misconceptions also. I mean, [crosstalk 01:16:43] there’s all kind.
You have countries that say you have to believe this and you do it like that.
You have groups that says it’s like this and you should do it. How is that?.
I can imagine that that is a lonely feeling when in this part of the world where they treat history ..
Prakhaim: Yes. In fact, that’s why we have to understand history in the proper way.
We don’t have to politicize history. This is the most dangerous thing.
Every group tries to say that, "I’m the one who follows the right way," but this is not true.
I mean, we have a basic ground, a basic ground which we have to understand it as it is.
We don’t have to reflect our political backgrounds on the culture.
If we politicize, I don’t know whether I’m using the right word, if we understand culture
and religion as well in their political context, definitely the result will be dangerous. Yeah.
Interviewer: You see that?
Prakhaim: Yes. In fact, that’s what’s happening now in the surrounding region. I mean, it’s difficult.
Yeah, every group has its own understanding
and they defend that in different ways because of the lack of cultural dialog. I’m dreaming of-
Interviewer: Could you explain to me what it means what you are doing, and what people you work with are doing,
for the enhancement of identity and the enrichment of identity?
Prakhaim: Yes. In fact, maybe as you have seen, that I’m working in different fields, but they are interrelated.
I’m using the information contained in the inscriptions in order to reach a certain result.
I’m using also information gained from cultural heritage in general, especially the intangible cultural heritage,
to put these results together in order to show how cultural heritage in general is important for identity.
In fact, identity is not contained only in inscriptions, but also in other sources.
I mean, for example, the Arabian poetry is part of our history. It’s part of our identity, or the Arabic poetry.
Also, the Holy Book, Koran, is also part of our identity.
Of course, it’s written in Arabic and I think it’s very crucial
and important to understand what the others wrote about Koran.
There are several institutions in Europe and the United States that take care … I mean,
that study Koran from a different perspective and a different methodology.
A lot of studies appeared in the last 20 years about Koran from Germany, France, and other countries in the world,
but I have the problem,
or I think I would suggest to the academic institutions in the Arab world to start understanding what the Europeans
wrote about this book, about this Holy Book in fact,
so that we can understand from the methodological level how the European scholars study Koran.
Because studying the Koran traditionally,
without taking into consideration the new publications written in different languages, for example in German, French
or Russian, I don’t know, I think it would lead to a kind of … I don’t know.
It could lead to a kind of misunderstanding of the others and their work concerning Koran.
Because it’s, for me, important to show how Europeans dealt with the Koran in general especially in the last 20,
50 years ago.
All their literature about Koran mostly translated into Arabic and we knew the contents of it, but in the last 20,
50 years, we have … I mean, Arab scholars who has no access to foreign languages, this will remain for them closed.
I mean, this literature written in other languages remains for them closed. They don’t know a lot about it.
That’s why I suggest that we start translating this into Arabic. Yeah.
Interviewer: That’s the core of who you are. I mean, languages are the key.
Prakhaim: Yes, are the key of cultures. Yeah.
Interviewer: Also to understand identity, your own identity.
Prakhaim: Yes, of course.
I mean, well, studying ancient written sources that are written in Arabian languages
and studying also their cultural connotations in addition to their cultural backgrounds,
and this would shed the light on the people who wrote these texts and also make them feel proud about our identity.
Interviewer: And understanding their identity.
Prakhaim: Yeah, and to understand it in a proper way. Yeah.
Interviewer: Yeah.
For that reason, the languages, the understanding of languages form the basis for … You know what I mean?
Prakhaim: Yes, of course. The languages are the keys.
They are the keys to cultures, and cultural values are contained in cultures.
Studying the languages is of course the key to understand the cultural backgrounds.
Especially regarding ancient civilizations, because they don’t exist anymore,
but we have the text that have been left by those who composed them.
We can get some glimpses about the cultural background from these texts
and they would help us in enhancing the identity.
Interviewer: That’s why your work is so important.
Prakhaim: Thank you very much.
Interviewer: Don’t you think yourself that it's important?
Prakhaim: Yeah, of course.
I mean, I think it’s an important discipline, which should be supported in every Jordanian institution.
Academic institution, I mean.
Interviewer: And by every Jordanian.
Prakhaim: Yes, of course.
First of all, we have to start in the academic institutions,
and then we should think in a further step how to disseminate this knowledge among the local communities.
Interviewer: Yeah..
There’s also people that visit Petra, for example, understand what Petra is and that’s [crosstalk 01:25:01]
Prakhaim: Yes, of course. Yeah.
Interviewer: Because now it’s sometimes used as a kind of a … not a-
Prakhaim: Well, yeah, this is the difficult story to film because now Petra is being consumed,
if we remain investing it in this way.
I feel that Petra is part of our identity here in Jordan and we have to preserve it.
and safeguard it as a cultural space for the future generations because it is ..
I mean, a site like Petra is a place which is unparalleled in the world.
We are very proud to have it, but we have in the same time to do our best to safeguard it
and also to present it in a proper way.
In addition to it being as part of our identity in Jordan,
I think it’s also a source for income generation for the national income.
We have the ability here in Jordan to start working on the sites in a proper way to conserve it
and to safeguard it for future generations. This also can be applied to other sites in Jordan.
As you mentioned before, Jordan is a museum. It’s an open museum.
If you travel from the north to the south, you will always encounter cultural heritage sites or nature sites,
and they constitute of course a part of our local identity.
Interviewer: They only have to see it then?
Prakhaim: Yes. I mean, this is an important thing as well.
We have to make the people aware, aware of the importance of such archeological sites or heritage sites in general.
Interviewer: Because by understanding it, they understand their own identity?
Prakhaim: Yeah, definitely.
Interviewer: That they understand they are more than just an Islamic
or just they’re more … that there’s more than the Islamic history?
Prakhaim: Yes. In fact, I feel that this part is not certain. I mean, like-
Interviewer: Okay, okay.
Prakhaim: I mean, Islam is also a part of our history, part of our identity as well. If you want to … I don’t know.
Do you want me to say it again?
Interviewer: Well, you can say it in … Yeah, you can say it again the way you like.
Prakhaim: Yes.
In fact, it’s not only the cultural heritage is part of our identity
and the religious identity of the people who are living in Jordan is part of the entire identity of the Jordanian
community.
We have Muslims, we have Christians here in Jordan,
but they constitute … both religions here in Jordan are part of our identity as Jordanians in whole.
Interviewer: And Arabs as a whole?
Prakhaim: Yeah, yeah. As Arabs of course, yes.
Interviewer: Yeah. So a lot of work to do for you?
Prakhaim: Yes. In fact, I am an individual, but I’m trying my best.
As I mentioned, I hope that we can cooperate with the young generation too, then to have a group of researchers,
a group of interested people, not only from the academic institutions
but also from the local communities to work together
and to cooperate so that we can enhance our identity as Jordanians, as Muslims, Christians, and as Arabs.
Interviewer: Yeah.
Prakhaim: Yeah.